oui
et info intox et avec vous antoine
fenaux bonjour bonjour a faim on va
parler football ce soir avec une un fox
au tour de la coupe du monde au qatar
absolument raphaël et autour de ce tweet
et de cette photo en particulier que
vous allez apercevoir qu est-ce qu on y
voit un robot humanoïde tenant le fameux
drapeau d'un arbitre de touche et le
tweet de dire pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de la coupe du monde un robot
va devenir arbitres de touche pour le
mondial au qatar alors ça peut prêter à
sourire mais la publication il faut bien
dire a été assez largement relayé alors
un robot juge de touche au qatar ou pas
pour en avoir le coeur net hon proches
on procède à une simple recherche
d'image inversée j'en ai j'ai choisi cet
outil mais il en existe des dizaines
d'autres et on retourne donc cette photo
là que vous trouverez aussi sur celle ci
sur un une autre photo légèrement
différente mais vous l'apercevez le
fonds est strictement le même on est
donc sur un montage photo où vous l'avez
compris la photo en elle-même pourrait
tout à fait précis vient de cette banque
d'image on la voit elle montre un
arbitre de touche que vous apercevez
c'est la troisième photo à droite du
championnat anglais il s'appelle darren
cann et levé son drapeau pour signaler
un hors-jeu donc c'était lors d'un match
entre west ham et middlesbrough le 1er
octobre 2007 dont vous l'avez compris
pas de robot mais un photomontage donc
un photomontage mais qui s'appuie sur
une vraie information oui en tout cas en
partie c'est ça qui est intéressant sur
une expérimentation de la fifa celle du
hors-jeu semi-automatique une
technologie de détection des joueurs sur
le terrain et donc du fameux hors jeu
lors des matches à l'aide de
l'intelligence artificielle du rheu
recueil des données certains le
qualifient même de hors-jeu au robot la
fifa vous le voyez sur ce twitt à du
démenti en disant eh bien ce n'est pas
du hors-jeu robot elle a d'ailleurs
accompagné d'une petite vidéo
explicative avec le l'ancien patron des
arbitres italiens entière luigi colina
qui explique donc comment fonctionne ce
système le but lui bien c'est d'aider
les arbitres à la prise de décision
comme l'avare le procédé nous précise la
fifa dans cet article a été essayé lors
du mondial des clubs cette fois ci
c'était en 2021 alors verra-t-on ou pas
la technologie en action lors du
prochain mondial au qatar en novembre
prochain par ce pas sûr parce que pour
ça il faut que l'ifab qui est l'instance
qui gère les règles du jeu étrange sur
le sujet et ça ce n'est pas encore actée
ces dernières vous le voyez ici s'est
réuni à doha c'était lundi dernier sans
prendre de décision sur ce sujet en
particulier en tout cas il faut 10
rafale et pour finir là-dessus que ce
mondial au qatar soulève de nombreuses
critiques on le dit on le répète sur les
conditions de travail et des ouvriers
qui ont fabriqué les stades et aussi sur
certaines polémiques on pense notamment
à ces fameux stades climatisés un
souvenez-vous avec des chaleurs
caniculaires en sévissant dans ce petit
émirat gazier certaines enceintes seront
ainsi refroidies et tant pis donc pour
le climat en parlant du capa vous avez
une autre un fox et elle concerne cette
fois les femmes oui un phoque s'est un
petit peu voire même beaucoup plus
sérieuse et avec cette photo vous la
voyez on y voit une femme intégralement
voilée sur un plateau de télévision en
train de se tenir la tête et le tweet de
dire la présentatrice qatari fatima
chèques sur la télévision nationale
exprime son inquiétude sur la liberté
religieuse en 1 de la publication elle a
été largement relayé quasiment vingt
mille like vous le voyez est largement
partagée alors info ou intox et bien là
encore recherche d'image inversé on
retourne sur cette photo de nos
confrères de et hippies qui nous donne
le fin mot de l'histoire et en lisant la
légende on s'aperçoit qu'il ne s'agit
pas du tout d'une qatari mais d'une
afghane la photo elle date vous le voyez
du 22 mai dernier elles montrent la
présentatrice caté raid hamadi très
affecté par la décision des talibans à
l'époque ces derniers ont obligé les
femmes et les journalistes représentant
donc des journaux passant la télévision
à se couvrir le visage décision qui
touche également toutes les femmes
afghanes c'est contre décision contre
laquelle elle avait pour certaines mais
courageusement manifester ou et cet
extrait de reportage nos confrères de
reuters que j'ai choisis pour vous et
cette décision les présentatrices à
vienne s'y était opposée elle aussi oui
dans un premier temps et certaines
avaient pendant un temps refusé de s'y
plier mais elle avait face à la pression
du 6 contre 1 2 voulais vous montrer ce
tweet d'une deux présentatrices afghane
elle s'appelle yalda alice est une des
présentatrices de la chaîne tolo news
une chaîne très populaire en afghanistan
et elle est en larmes en apprenant cette
décision des talibans elle dit dans le
tweet que vous voyez ici mon sourire est
interdite ma bouche est fermé et bientôt
la femme sera bannie nos confrères des
hommes si je vais en terminer là dessus
on d'ailleurs interrogés pour 1
d'ailleurs interrogé 1 pour un article
sur le sujet je vous le renvoie
d'ailleurs à l'expliquer la peur que les
talibans ont installé chez les femmes et
elle explique avoir tenté de résister
peut-être être résigné et à l'ifth a
raison si j'abandonne maintenant les
talibans atteindront leur objectif
ultime qui est d'éliminer totalement les
fans de la société et je ne les
laisserai pas faire merci antoine fenaux
c'était info intox avec antoine rester
avec nous par israël continue avec dans
un instant le journal de l'afrique
[Musique]